herr tag elf nach der bundestagswahl und
am machtpoker tisch da sitzen spd fdp
die grünen ja und wir sprechen jetzt
über die männer die union auch noch ein
bisschen dabei die über die zukunft von
deutschlands entscheiden und darüber wer
von ihnen die besten karten hat und
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit bild chef
julian reichelt guten morgen bei uns im
studio geborgen ja mit uns am pokertisch
sozusagen hier hinter uns sieht toll aus
so ungefähr stellen unsere kollegen sich
das in diesen tagen vor mit olaf scholz
so im nebenrollen im moment armin
laschet markus thema die seite und wie
der christian lindner und robert habe
hier mit den hut krempen ins gesicht
gezogen am pokertisch wie knöpfen uns
diese fünf männer jetzt mal in ruhe vor
julian sprechen zuerst über olaf scholz
der ist als erster heute angetroffen wir
haben die bilder karte schon gesehen
ganz frisch schon kurz vor 8 also eher
als erster heute da hat er die besten
karten das beste blatt aktuell auf der
hand so wie er grinst so wie er grinst
hat auf jeden fall die besten karten ich
finde vor allem erst einmal
bemerkenswert wenn wir uns den wahlkampf
noch einmal vergegenwärtigen ja und
besonders den wahlkampf von annalena
baerbock vergegenwärtigen und wie oft
gesagt wurde wenn jemand inhaltliche
kritik an annalena baerbock
vorgetragen hat dass das ja eigentlich
sexistisch sein es ist doch schon
bemerkenswert dass die macht in
deutschland jetzt nahezu ausschließlich
noch von männern verhandelt wird
annalena baerbock darf natürlich noch
mit auf der bühne stehen ist aber
vollkommen klar dass robert habeck dabei
den grünen die macht übernommen hat die
verhandlungsmacht übernommen hat und
tatsächlich etwas was man sich
eigentlich gar nicht mehr vorstellen
konnte liegt jetzt die zukunft
deutschlands die zukunft der deutschen
regierung ausschließlich anhand von
männern keine frau hat da im moment
signifikant was zu sagen aus meiner
sicht ein eher bedenklicher zustand olaf
scholz natürlich der mann mit dem besten
blatt auf der hand natürlich derjenige
der einen spektakulären wahlsieg für die
spd eingefahren hat natürlich derjenige
der das bisher alles auch sehr cool
gehandhabt hat aber was man nicht
vergessen darf die beiden kleineren
partner fdp und grüne am tisch haben
zusammen eine stimme macht die
ebenbürtig ist mit der von olaf scholz
das heißt olaf scholz deswegen dritter
derzeit auch so eher demütig auf weil er
weiß diese beiden und das haben wir
durch dieses er fiel deutlich gemacht
sind eine eine macht gegen die auch
jederzeit aufstehen kann und seine
kanzler träumen beenden kann deswegen
olaf scholz so etwas wie der mächtigste
mann am tisch vor grün-gelben geladen
aber christian lindner der müsste doch
dann der mächtigste mann am tisch sein
oder vor welchen herausforderungen steht
er jetzt gerade christian lindner hat
natürlich mit seinem wahlergebnis etwas
historisches geschafft für die fdp
nämlich zum zweiten mal hintereinander
zweistellig ist der fdp der geschichte
der bundesrepublik noch nie gelungen und
so geht christian lindner gerade auch
ungefähr durch berlin sehr sehr
selbstbewusst aber das hat nicht nur den
grund dass er eben dieses historische
wahlergebnis was das gesamtergebnis an
geht darum hat es hat auch etwas damit
zu tun dass er etwas geschafft hat was
auch das geht die ganze medienlandschaft
in berlin für unmöglichkeiten hat die
jungen leute gewonnen er hat die jungen
leute gewonnen unter den erstwählern hat
er das stärkste ergebnis 23 prozent
unter den fünf und unter 25-jährigen das
zweitstärkste ergebnis 22 prozent es ist
nicht so dass es eine generation greta
gibt wo alle grün wählen und alle ihren
autoschlüssel mit in die wahlurne werfen
wollen und stattdessen auf lasten
fahrrad umsteigen wollen es gibt
tatsächlich eine junge generation in
deutschland die will offenbar arbeiten
die will offenbar aufsteigen die will
offenbar weniger steuern zahlen dass er
christian lindner mit diesem
wahlergebnis
bewiesen und das gibt ihnen natürlich
ein besonderes mandat sozusagen für die
zukunft unseres landes zu sprechen
fünf männer die über die macht in
deutschland jetzt entscheiden sagst du
julian wir nehmen uns mal den dritten
vor robert habeck hier bei unserem
pokertisch ganz am rande hat der trumpf
wichtige trümpfe in der hand und was
könnte ihm gefährlich werden in diesem
poker ja robert habeck der manchmal
etwas bullig wirkende polit philosoph am
pokertisch hat in eine ähnliche
ausgangssituation wie robert h wie
christian lindner auch er hat ein
wahlergebnis errungen beziehungsweise
die grünen haben besserung das unter den
jungen menschen besonders starke werte
ausweist sehr vergleichbar mit denen der
fdp und er hat den zeitgeist auf sein
seit er weiß das große thema unserer
zeit der klimawandel egal was man davon
was man davon hält wie wie schwer dieses
thema gewichtet ist ist ganz klar bei
den grünen verortet eine regierung ohne
die grünen ist derzeit aufgrund dieses
themas schon geradezu undenkbar und das
weiß robert habeck natürlich und genau
so geht er rein allerdings muss ich
sagen hat man in den letzten tagen nie
das gefühl gehabt dass er deswegen
irgendwie % oder kraftstrotzend da
reingeht sondern er hat diese ja diese
manchmal etwas brumme leger art die aber
oft eine gewisse weise auch bescheiden
wird ich glaube robert habeck weiß dass
er derzeit der richtige mann am
richtigen ort zur richtigen zeit ist und
er hat sehr sehr sehr geschickt ohne das
irgendwie machohaft erscheint zu lassen
annalena baerbock zur seite gedrückt die
karten als der hand genommen vorher
gerade beim poker sind deswegen auch
keine frauen lasst uns weiter schauen in
diesem pokerspiel markus oehl da eine
ganz zentrale figur hat sich vor allem
auch gestern gezeigt ja markus söder hat
gestern das haben wir ja auch berichtet
quasi die noch letzten verbleibenden
jamaica träume und damit kanzler träumen
von armin laschet der zunichte gemacht
und hat gesagt man muss jetzt die
realitäten anerkennen es wird jetzt eben
die ampel
wir wir sind im prinzip raus hat er
gesagt während armin laschet in einem
für mich etwas bizarr anmutenden
statement gesagt hat das hat sich
eigentlich nichts geändert und man steht
weiter zu verhandlungen bereit bei armin
laschet hat mich besonders gewundert wie
man in einem
freien land mit freie presse noch ein
presse statement abgeben kann und sich
dann einfach nur 60 sekunden umdrehen
ohne eine einzige frage anzunehmen also
unsere varena wird es dann auch nicht
mehr armin laschet wirkte da auch schon
ziemlich bedröppelt und markus söder hat
nachdem armin laschet gesagt hat wir
stehen weiter bereit und das kann
eigentlich alles so weitergehen nur
minuten später deutlich gemacht hier
geht gar nichts mehr so weiter es ist
jetzt so sei auch eine frage der
selbstachtung das hier zu beenden dafür
muss markus söder im moment natürlich
mal wieder viel kritik einstecken es
geht dann da immer wieder um seinen
charakter und wir auf armin laschet los
geht die armin laschet truppen sind
unterwegs und versuchen diese niederlage
sozusagen als menschliche vernichtung
von armin laschet zu finden man muss
aber ganz klar sagen armin laschet hat
ganz eigenhändig und fast im alleingang
das ergebnis das wahlergebnis der cdu
vor der volkspartei cdu auf dem gewissen
und ich finde es immer interessant wie
es um diese charakterfragen geht ja
jetzt sagen hallo ihr aber der markus
söder vielleicht wär s mit magst du dann
noch schlimmer weil er
hört man immer wieder oft so einen
schlechten charakter ich würde sagen
wenn markus söder da jetzt als
wahlgewinner als kanzlerkandidat und
wahlgewinner sitzen würde dann würde
niemand in der cdu in berlin sagt ja 30
prozent aber der markt ist wieder der
charakter das ist alles schwierig das
ist schon das hohe spiel der bigotterie
was da im politischen berlin gerade
aufgeführt wird jetzt noch einmal am
tisch bleibt julian an den pokertisch
bleiben da haben wir markus söder und
armin laschet noch mit drangesetzt
einige würden jetzt sagen moment mal
moment mal die verhandeln auch die ampel
da sind die doch bald gar nicht mehr am
tisch aber doch die pokern da noch mit
nämlich mit welchen karten warum ist
laschet im moment noch als trumpf
gefragt und warum pokert irgendwie
markus söder da im hintergrund auch noch
mit also ich glaube armin laschet sitzt
im prinzip ohne karten und ohne chips
damit am tisch armin laschet hat keine
trümpfe in der hand jeder weiß dass
armin laschet nicht der nächste
bundeskanzler wird armin laschet weiß
ist eigentlich auch möchte es aber noch
nicht so richtig eingestehen ich glaube
da läuft am kommenden montag wenn das
cdu-präsidium tag sozusagen die frist ab
woher der noch würde voll rauskommen und
von sich aus sagen kann das war es jetzt
für mich ich muss sagen für die große
marke cdu für die große volkspartei cdu
für das lager der bürgerlichen wird es
langsam ja grenzt ist langsam an
beschämend diese form von
wirklichkeitsverweigerung da immer zu
sitzen und so zu tun als ging alles ganz
normal weiter ich finde dass es auch
eine tonalität in der man nicht mit
deutschland spricht ja so zu tun als
wäre alles als wäre alles in ordnung als
hätte man noch alle chancen wenn das
ganze land drumherum sieht hier haben
wir das war ein in den
satz von armin laschet in diesen 60
sekunden gestern dieses ganz kurze
knappe statement an einem historischen
tag ja eigentlich hat er nur das gesagt
in den letzten tagen mit fdp und grünen
die fdp hat signalisiert dass es in sehr
vielen punkten
übereinstimmung gibt mit der union wir
haben signalisiert wir stehen auch zu
weiteren gesprächen bereit wir stehen
bereit als gesprächspartner cdu und csu
wir stehen bereits sagt armin laschet
muss er überhaupt noch bereit stehen
viele wählerinnen und wähler fragen sich
heute an so einem tag weil es die ersten
sondierungsgespräche stattfinden ist
überhaupt jamaika irgendwie noch in den
karten drin die frage ist vor allem wen
meint armin laschet mit video denn wenn
man sich umhört in der cdu gibt es noch
ich armin laschet und dann gibt es die
cdu da glaubt niemand mehr daran dass
armin laschet die cdu in jamaika
fahndung oder gar erfolgreiche jamaika
verhandlungen führen wird die meinung
hat armin laschet ganz allein für sich
[Musik]